job
in lemmings your task is to instruct a
number of extremely stupid creatures in
the subtle art of not falling off cliffs
at first of course you'll fail and every
time one of your little charges falls to
its doom turning into pixelated paste
your heart will develop another hairline
crack but after a while you get used to
it and then you start to kind of enjoy
it an animal crossing you actually start
the game out in debt to a raccoon so the
game involves doing menial labor to pay
off your unreasonable mortgage a theme
that I'm sure is very popular nowadays
in addition to that you're constantly
nagged by these huge headed animal
creatures who are always bugging you for
presents and favors and rewarding you
with ugly wallpaper and demeaning
nicknames and then on top of this if you
take a break for a couple weeks or a
couple months and you come back the
village is choked with weeds so you in
this game are responsible for the
economic prosperity and civic pride of a
bunch of ungrateful freaks I imagine
it's a lot like being on the Berkeley
City Council now let's face it every
hour spent playing a video game is
obviously a tower you could spend doing
something else but the Sims is unusual
in that everything you're doing in the
game is the same thing that you'd be
doing in real life if you weren't
playing the game things like working or
making friends or going to the bathroom
many people have commented on this
recursive quality of the sims but very
few realize that each cycle of the
recursion is powered by a tiny crumb of
your soul which means that if you play
the sims enough your Sims become real
they gain the ability to think and to
love and to pity what you've become
Nintendogs is a game where you take care
of a puppy that never grows up you feed
it you walk it you play with it forever
it never ends I took a break from
nintendogs after I played it for a while
and I could never bring myself to go
back I understand the dogs probably fine
I think it like runs away and comes back
or something but in my mind it's sitting
there that tiny little cartridge just
staring at the door month after month I
just I just can't face the dog again
knowing what I've done to it anyhow
world of warcraft has three distinct
levels of guilt it is a guilt parfait to
begin with it is a huge time sink there
are just hours and hours to be sunk into
it saving the world from
interdimensional demon creatures or
roving undead or possibly woodland
animals depending on your level secondly
even after you've spent all this time on
it you're never going to do everything
in the game you're not going to play all
the classes or do all the quests or get
all the pets they recently added
achievements to the game which for me is
just a big list of everything i'm not
going to do and finally there are guilds
actual people some of whom are friends
who are counting on you to help them get
the maple bad of the mafia enforcer or
something equally ludicrous one of the
warcraft wins for being the only game
that makes me feel equally guilty
whether I'm playing it or not playing it
you